[Music]
words like legitimate and
proportionate will mean little to
susie-ish quintana
rescued from the rubble she lost her
mother and all four siblings in one of
hundreds of israeli airstrikes on gaza
this month
israel says they were unintended
casualties of a mission
against the territories hamas rulers
that can such force be justified
this fighter pilot flew an f-15 jet
armed with precision guided bombs during
the 11-day operation
every civilian casualty is tragic
whether it's in gaza
whether it's in israel i am here to
defend the israeli civilians
the 29 year old tells me the air force
aborts attacks
if civilians are identified on the
ground
yet the conflict left more than 60
children dead
we spoke the day before a ceasefire was
agreed
what would you say to the children whose
parents and
siblings have been killed because of
this operation
when you ask that question what i
visualize is
what's happening here in in israel at
the end of the day israeli lives and
civilians
are being targeted which is different
but are also dying at the end of the day
i don't want to imagine a situation or a
reality
where people have to lose loved ones
simply because they were in the area how
worried are you that you're potentially
taking part in
an operation that could be equated to
war crimes i know every target that is
carried out by the israeli air force
has the entire
operation behind it also in the air and
also on the ground making sure that
every target that we target is one hamas
related
and two cleared in order to limit every
attack from severity of civilian
casualties that's our mission legal
experts say
simply being hamas related may not be
sufficient to justify attacks that also
cause civilian harm
let's assume that a legitimate target is
attacked
then comes in the proportionality rule
the proportionality is not number of
victims
on both sides but for each attack
between the military advantage and the
expected
harm among the civilian population
the destruction in gaza including
infrastructure like buildings
roads and power lines damaged each time
this conflict
sits uncomfortably with a former israeli
sniper
he's now part of a group critical of
israel's offensives
we have the right to defend ourselves
right but the question that we need to
ask ourselves
is what we're doing in gaza strip or by
the way in the west bank are defending
israel
and no i think the answer is no gaza
doesn't have a military
solution israel insists all its attacks
were legal
and that some of gaza's trauma was
caused by misfired hamas munitions
it also accuses the group of war crimes
for firing rockets like these
against civilian targets in israel from
the cover
of civilian neighborhoods in gaza a
claim hamas denies
the un's top human rights body plans to
investigate the actions by both sides
it's a move israel has rejected but
comes
as scrutiny of this decades-long turmoil
grows
debrahing sky news israel